Now, we're going to display the notes.
We have a storyboard, and
our storyboard has been updated with
a table VC, a table view controller.
Also, we have a nodes view
controller class that inherits from
core data table view controller, and has
a pretty standard cell forRowIndexPath.
We get the note, we get the cell and we
sync note and sell and return the sell.
The interesting part really isn't
that prepare for say on notebooks VC.
Let's take a look at it
the first thing we need
is a fetch request for the notes.
Next, we need to specify how
we'd like them to be sorted, so
we going to do that by creationDate and
also by the text.
The next step would be to create
the NSFetchedResultsController and
we inject it into the notes view
controller and we can display it.
Let's take a look at how this displays.
So have the notebooks and
I'll select these notes,
the ones in Coding Notes,
and we get them all.
Instead of two, we get three.
So what is missing here?
What's missing is a way to
filter only those notes that we
are interested in in this case those
that belong to the specific notebook.
And the way to filter the circuit result
by adding an instance of an NS predicate
to our fetch request NS predicate is
a class that filters the search results.
It can be configured with
a special micro language
called predicate query language.
Don't worry about that.
It's extremely simple.
So let's add one to a fetched request.
The easiest way to create an NS
predicate is with the format string.
So in order to create the predicate
first of all we need to find
what's the exact notebook
that we're selecting
at this point because we will need
that information in order to filter.
So first thing we get
the indexPathForSelectedRow and
then with objectAtIndexPath
we obtain the Notebook.
Always remember to cast it to Notebook.
Once we have this you can go ahead and
create the predicate.
The easiest way is using this
initialize and this predicate.
And then, a format which is simply
a string, a kind of a template string,
and an array of arguments of
objects that will be substituted or
inserted into the template.
So the template simply states notebook,
that means the property notebook,
of the note must be equal to.
And this is a marker that says that
we're going to substitute here
an object.
What object?
The notebook.
So it's that easy.
We're just saying the notebook.
Must be equal to this one and
you're done add it to the fetch
request and if you run.
You have two notes and
once we click here.
We only get it.
So yeah it's that simple,
check it out for yourself.
And I also recommend you take a look
at the NSPredicate documentation
as you can create very
complex filters with it.
We barely scratched the surface and
it's an extremely powerful class.
Definitely a tool worth
having under your belt.